okay all right it's okay hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
quadrant if you couldn't tell by the
orchestra playing it's comforting music
this is a horror game where horrible
things happen to everybody involved and
no one is going to get out alive
actually I don't know that at all I'm
just going to play this game July relax
mark mark we got a covered don't worry
we'll do you ready to fill us in there
yeah should be okay now they didn't want
me to brief you until we were well
within the vicinity what's the situation
mark got a call from the facility
something about a leak we were the
closest sort of job would does seems a
bit odd they wouldn't bring in a bigger
team apparently it's urgent
marks that the color sounded panicked I
guess it didn't matter who came as long
as someone came quick they probably just
called the first number they saw on file
whatever it is we'll get it done yeah
and fast hopefully I might actually get
back in time to leave tonight you headed
out somewhere I was I was gonna take my
family up to the lake the weekend we
were supposed to leave tonight no chance
of that now yeah this leek really should
have tried to work around your schedule
how I'm concerned let's just try to get
this done fast hmm
I'll get the door open okay John you
haven't said a word since we got here
she's just upset he had to come in today
that was your big night oh well it was
supposed to be yeah what is a promotion
well a consideration for a promotion hey
I'm sure that wait for you John hey John
none of us want to be here we'll be in
and out we've done this a hundred times
we'll be done before sunset why stop
saying things like that a single
elevator they must have had to make a
hundred trips to get everyone out of
here
and why are they all talking for me why
the thing horror cliches am i one day
from retirement I'm getting too old for
this [ __ ]
we're dealing with as far as I know
there were no details or at least I
wasn't briefed on any all we know is
that some kind of substance leak
possible radiation well I did do a quick
scan and see what we find
radioactive blood is it blond
might be blood pocket
which like there's no PowerPoint
if you require assistance security
visual guidance for you please remember
to proceed to your designated Quadra
home violation of this description will
result and detainment or dead report
[ __ ] looks like these doors are wrong on
everything should have been left open
for us like usual there's no keyhole
either must be an electronic system we
could overload the system to deactivate
the locks but I don't want to damage
anything that facility like this the
breaker will trip before it causes any
damage it'll give us a window long
enough to open the door I say give it a
shot John take the device in your bag
and find an outlet look for any open
doors there's probably now lit in one of
the offices okay you got it boss I'm the
silent protagonist who's probably gonna
die in horrible ways do I have a journal
that I jot all my ideas into is there
someone here it's gonna kill me oh boy
any monsters gonna PUC have no boo-boo
that wasn't words but I tried hard
that's all that matters okay am I
supposed to go in the door that somehow
blinking mysteriously hmm I've got a
good feeling about this one oh boy wait
where am I hello yeah I did a thing no
don't don't bother me oh okay press left
stick you got it hold it down you got it
okay there's a long way to go to find an
outlet who's over there huh
once he wants the deal will see
incredibly powerful John did I mention
my name is John
at the personality of a stone hey John
you find an outlet you know you can use
the device on any open L that you find
use the switches to activate all the
lights on the face of the device you'll
have to find the right combination to
get them all lit it should overload the
primary power source in the area and
cause the break of the trip great it's a
puzzle why do I have a device that's a
puzzle also where am I going
Oh like this I like this at all somebody
up there is that from Mass Effect I love
that game also where the hell am i oh
thanks I don't want none of that
back off monsters in the darkness oh hey
look at this
this looks vonner Abul can I do a thing
oh that is the thing okay so get this do
I have to get have to get all the lights
on okay cool thanks various rock samples
have arrived in our quadrant Oh what
interesting rocks everything's gonna
kill us
traits we include mathematically precise
20 degree angles various hues I've
assembled my team as of 606 o'clock
today okay names will be omitted also
their lives are forfeit I've been
hearing stip steps the entire time I've
been here I don't like it
should I be worried about you know the
noises that I'm hearing all the
wonderful horrible awesome noises
darkness hello darkness my old enemy
hello are all my friends still alive
goody goody gumdrops hello John you can
take the West Wing there might be some
documentation on the substances they
have here oh sure yeah sure okay I'll
take the dangerous route I don't know
which way is west is this this is West
whoever I better flaps look at this
whole time I had no idea
alrighty then I'll take all the West
Wing it's the door that's open I should
have known
I wonder why maybe it's a horrible
monstrosity I'm seeing stuff scattered
all over the place
me too yes yes sir
must have been a serious leak people
were this panic trying to get out yeah
hee hee hee mm-hmm significant damage
has occurred in the facility's basement
storage corridors various pipes have
been broken and this has caused a
substantial flood in the area a team has
altered the channels and ceased to flow
of water
however the staff accountable for the
segments truss it is right now hazardous
to proceed into the area blah blah blah
blah blah bad shits going down also why
is 1979
I wonder what's so important about this
period in time or if anything important
is about it is about it that was English
ok what's this ooh what do I do with
that
the doors in my area just slam shut
I'm thinking the facility system must be
malfunctioning anyway if I can't find a
way out I'll try and navigate to the air
ducts okay
I don't know I'm my flashlight just went
out for her okay okay
all right that's okay I'm a little jumpy
okay just bear with me everybody bear
with me I'll get through it okay loud
noises nothing bad happening here I'm
okay I'm just a big baby oh no I'm
scared now I'm sure I'm sure there'll be
something perfectly acceptable to be
terrified of in just a little bit who's
that
what's that huh oh yeah I'll go through
the fence oh it's a good idea oh it's
the best idea I've ever had hey guys I
found some use of something a lot of it
is it thought it might be our substance
but it's not showing any readings looks
a lot like maybe someone just got
injured on their way out just just keep
looking Oh YUM find me some damn info we
need to know what we're dealing with
here did you say John or Pam ham John
Jim Jim once where's Mark also what's
with that constant banging then I found
something this is definitely blood it's
smeared all the way in any of the room
wait something else Oh No
you can wave or something I'm bigger oh
my god I can't even tell what do it then
you will be coming Donna I'm dead ends
gone so I've been picking up fuses and
I'm assuming that I need to get them in
here for the Foos so I need two more I
guess I'm just gonna have to find him on
the way let's grab this one just in case
okay I got another fuse don't know if I
even needed it but I got it so we're
good there
it's my little rat buddy here oh look at
the tiny rat you better get out of here
everyone's gonna come murder you I don't
even know what to name you Marlon Marlon
Lyndon that's Marley Lyndon the mouse
everybody say bye to Marla Lyndon we are
not going to ever see him again
Oh Marla Lyndon the mouse thank you're
not nuts cute a name is Tim or nothing
but you're adorable just by yourself Oh
Marla Lyndon Marlon Marlon and Marla
Lyndon I miss you already
what the hell do I do no it's open okay
good why did I want to come in here for
what was this purpose why am I do this
hello thank you for your inquiry but I'm
afraid you have been informed much too
late
it has already come to my attention that
various moon rock samples have become
missing
I'm incredibly baffled by the way of the
lower divisions of the facility handles
that why no material was hutch disregard
I am requesting an accountability and
assurance meeting I am a world I knows
about the bins I've loved the facility
I've Logan with our various guards in
Washington well I'm still incredibly
frustrated that they're loitering on the
counter for fix this nameless dude so is
this important
probably not okay so they brought
something back from the moon that they
didn't want to bring back
pam-pam you wanna give me a little hidey
ho on the radio hey how you doing
maybe John I'm heading back something's
wrong we need to find Ben and then we
need to get the hell out of here
yeah finding that list of substances
just meet you back in the lobby ASAP
okay all right cool will do except
you're probably gonna be dead by the
time you get to that point Tommy who's
that something screaming good how are
you hearing man what the hell is it
well that was certainly unexpected [ __ ]
me don't even think about it I know good
food I'm a comic come out for you only
Marla Linden we're here
Marla Linden would protect me from the
demons from space and the moon thereby
ever watch that one horror movie where
they went to the moon and like the
Russians were also there and like they
found aliens aliens on the moon this is
actually a pretty smoothie oh boy oh is
this the strange substance we're
supposed to clean up there's this paint
oh wow wow wow wow hands at you Oh
you look different did you do something
to your hair I better follow the trail
of blood that's good oh boy oh boy oh
boy
this ain't good it ain't good at all
isn't okay okay so so alright then I'm
suddenly getting a big SCP vibe just
from the layout of the architecture here
but then again it was just a series of
corridors oh there's oh good whoa I bet
it whoa
whew okay cool all right so that's all
the time I got for the first episode
I'm gonna continue this game right away
and holy crap it's actually really good
it was a bit of a slow start but
definitely got into it well I mean I
haven't even seen the monster yet and I
was already creeping out jumping in my
own shadow so let me know what you think
of this game down in the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
oh boy a robo box cutter are those
Rumble the whole families